محمد رمضان يكشف عن مفاجاه على الزيرو حلا
شيحه تقول كفى للمسيئين وحادثه في موقع
تصوير في المقادير اليكم الابرز في اسبوع
[موسيقى]
بعد كل الجدل الذي اثير حول الممثله
المصريه على شيحه خلال السنوات الماضيه
بشان اعتزالها وعودتها للفن وتكرار
التزامها بالحجاب وخلعه اعطى نقيب المهن
التمثيليه في مصر اشرف زكي انطباعا عن
امكانيه ترحيب الوسط الفني المصري بعودتها
للتمثيل مجددا في مقابله اعلاميه اجريت
معهم مؤخرا تحدث فيها عن تواصل حلى معه
ورغبتها في ذلك
حبيبتنا يعني يعني هي كلمتني على فكره
يعني حصل بيني وبينها تواصل يعني
بالمناسبه يعني ومن جهتها توجهت حلا شيحه
بالشكر لاشرف زكي الذي وصفته بالسند لكل
مبدع مصري وشكرت زملائها الفنانين
المصريين على دعمها وتحدثت عن مرورها
باربع سنوات في حياتها كانوا من اصعب ما
يكون بحسب قولها كما شكرت ايضا من وصفتهم
بجمهورها الجميل واعتذرت عن اي كلمه بدلت
منها خرجت في وقت حرج من حياتها قائله لم
اقصد ابدا الاساءه لاحد ولا احمل الا كل
الحب واتمنى الخير لكل الناس ودعت
المتابعين الذين يسيئون لها في التعليقات
الى الخروج من حسابها
ووسط الجدل الذي يدور عالميا حول ذكاء
الاصطناعي اعلن الفنان المصري عمرو مصطفى
عن يده اطلاق ما وصفه باول مطرب اي اي في
العالم قريبا فرد عليه المطرب المصري احمد
سعد بصوره طريفه علق عليها بالقول احنا
اسرنا معك في حاجه
[موسيقى]
ونبقى في اجواء الغناء حيث اثار الفنان
المصري محمد رمضان حماسه متابعه بصوره
ومقاطع فيديو نشرها عبر حساباته الرسميه
على منصات التواصل كشف فيها عن تحضيرات
لعمل غنائي جديد في رومانيا وبدا رمضان في
اطالته الجديده حليق الراس على الزيرو
وتزامن ذلك مع اعلان شركه العدل جروب عن
تاجيل اطلاق فيلمه المقبل على الزيرو
بالشراكه مع الفنانه المصريه نيللي كريم
لما بعد منافسات موسم افلام عيد الاضحى
نظرا لعدم انتهاء تصوير الفيلم بحسب بيان
صادر عن الشركه
[موسيقى]
سينمائيا ايضا اسفلت حادثه في موقع تصوير
الجزء الثاني من فيلم في المغرب عن اصابه
العديد من الاشخاص المشاركين في الانتاج
وذلك اثناء تصوير حيله مخطط لها بحسب
مقاله متحدث باسم الشركه المنتجه في بيان
شاركه مع شبكه سي ان ان واوضح ان جميع من
تعرضوا للاصابه تلقوا الرعايه اللازمه على
الفور وجميعهم في حاله مستقره وما زالوا
يتلقون العلاج ويخرج الجزء الثاني من
غلاديتر الذي اخرج الجزء الاول الحائز على
جوائز الاوسكار في عام 2000
[موسيقى]